[Music]
did john's connection with nick
play in his hire
nick
uh
oh oh i was like nick who
um
zero yeah zero at all zero
oh that's just not convincing you know i
saw the words on paper but to see that
and hear it right doug marone knows he
can't say anything about nick foles i
mean it's
this is why coaches get mad at the media
they tried to set him up to commit a
tampering violation either it was clumsy
or it was deliberate but he can't talk
about nick foles he's the property of
the philadelphia evil so what else is he
going to say guys he can't say anything
he's got to say nick who he's got to say
no he that is a situation where you
can't say anything but no
nor is he going to tip his hand i think
at this point either so that you know
that's the other thing i mean yes that
was a very nice acting job by him there
all together it was not a good it was
not a good acting job that's what made
it so good you know
no no i'm gonna throw this just out
there i think the the number like nick
foles certainly could be there and maybe
they'd get rid of blake and they go
let's bring nick foles in but i think
the biggest thing too is they're i think
they're gonna try to make a play for
dwayne haskins that's the way i really
look at it so yeah maybe maybe they get
nick foles but i really think the guy
that they want is going to be dwayne
haskins at ohio state i think he fits a
lot of what they are about a big guy who
can move a little bit when need be but
can throw the ball down the field he
certainly could orchestrate the uh
default ball offense as well listen
everyone tampers always just always
remember that in all sports you know it
everyone's right but you can't you can't
do it at all no it's just so funny to me
because everyone's like oh he can't say
anything well guess what there's
conversations being happy right now said
this year that he's got players texting
them everywhere they want to come play
for the race game it's such a silly game
just everyone let out get out there and
say hey we want nick foles who cares
so do you want nick falls or blake
bortles or is that the dumbest question
i've ever asked big cat no i mean i
think i think listen i think
jacksonville is going to move on from
blake bortles and that's the biggest
mistake they'll ever make in their
entire franchise history but that's okay
you know what sometimes you gotta you
gotta let people just fail over and over
and over and i know i'll disagree with
chris because he hates blake bortles not
only as a football player but as a
person he told me that
i have some stats for you though you're
ready for this okay right uh would you
say peyton manning's a good quarterback
yes all right so first four years in the
league peyton manning 84 interceptions
blake bortles 61 that's a pretty big
difference that is a pretty big that's a
pretty big difference okay uh who's the
best young quarterback in the nfl right
now the best young quarterback in the
nfl right now whether you i mean you
want to say deshawn watson no you're
making
i mean there's i think there's one guy
who's playing this weekend well yeah
patrick mahomes
chris
caught me off guard best young
quarterback in the nfl mike i have a
question for you name the two
quarterbacks since the merger who in
their year two in the nfl had 4 000
yards passing 35 plus tds and over 250
yards rushing okay wait i have i have a
feeling i have a feeling it's going to
be patrick mahomes and blake porter
thank you i have a feeling i know where
it is patrick mahomes and blake portals
they are essentially one in the same i
would take either or on my team right
now all right he's insane here okay i
like blake bortles the person i really
do and i really you didn't say that i
i'll admit i lied i lied about that
we're having fun i understand that and
um i really do i feel bad about this at
times because i don't mean to attack
anybody personally it's really just a
football thing and i try to be state of
that now
to to big cat's point is stats like oh
oh yeah the the yards and the numbers
you know all that's great and that looks
really good but if you went back context
matters in these situations where you go
back and you go well damn they were down
31-7 because he threw two interceptions
early in the game and the game was over
and then he got 250 yards the last 12
minutes of the game because they were
being blown out that's how you throw for
4 500 yards if you're like bortles that
sounds like the brett favre to me also a
hall of fame
wow
that is not fair along with like
something like peyton manning from day
one okay just to dispel that whole
number myth he had there you know
numbers never lie they were going please
peyton manning carried the organization
from day one with blake bortles they
were going oh
we hope we don't have to ever have you
carry us or we're in deep crap and we
saw this year that he kind of had to
carry them and they finally said okay
fine uh we we're finally admitting we're
wrong here and going to move on even
though they're closing the super bowl
window because they wouldn't check their
egos at the door and move on at the
appropriate time well a couple plays
away from going to the super bowl last
year that's all i'm going to say yes
there's no doubt let me take this back
let me take this back to where it
started though because
chris you mentioned dwayne haskins as a
possibility for the jaguars i would
think that they would err on the side of
getting a veteran because they have a
team that that is close and and you
don't want to break in a new guy but two
years ago they passed on patrick mahomes
and drafted leonard fournette and you
have to wonder how much they're going to
be thinking about that and not wanting
to miss out on somebody who could be the
nfl's next big thing whether it's
haskins whether it's kyler murray
whether it's whoever will they go the
other way because they blew it with
mahomes two years ago and they did vote
could you imagine that jaguars team all
due respect for blake bortles yeah could
you imagine that jaguars team with
patrick mahomes right now they'd be
playing this weekend yeah well yeah i
mean of course i mean mahomes is special
we know that we haven't seen many people
in the history of the sport like well
and blake
we have seen someone like that his name
was blake bortles but prove that point
i'm even saying the dwayne haskins
things because i mean mike you know i
know a few people around the nfl i have
heard through the rumorville that
they're hot on dwayne haskins i wouldn't
be surprised if they made a move to get
up the draft a little bit and make a
play for him so maybe the giants or
somebody like that won't steal him first
yeah they better keep their mouths shut
or they're not going to have a chance at
him it's a little early to be letting
letting the secrets out about who you're
looking for the draft isn't until late
april but we'll see how all that plays
out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports